accuracy and our presentation of this site so we'll start off with the accuracy first
so your accuracy it's actually scored from a four so from the number four you're actually marked
during your presentation of your pattern and then with that one any mistakes that you make
whether if it's a minor mistake you get a minus of a 0.1 if it's a major mistake you get minus 0.3
so i'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two so with a minor mistake
it's a very very small thing so say we're doing a out of block if it's not your shoulder height
maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's a minor mistake so that's
0.1 a major mistake would be you're supposed to do an out of block in the pattern but you forget
and you say you do a rich hand strike instead so that would be a major mistake so with
minor mistake let's say pattern one for example there's 20 steps it's not uncommon to have up to
maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns sorry the 20 steps so the reason for that one being
it needs to be absolutely perfect to get to not get a deduction of 0.1
so it's not uncommon let's say there's 20 steps and you made let's say 15 mistakes
so what would that be so we'll leave that there on this side and we'll come back and we'll just
calculate the score at the end so a major mistake say you're supposed to turn to the left when you
turn to the right that would be a major mistake so obviously we do want to try to avoid any of
these major mistakes so after we've done our pattern that's when we move on to the presentation
side so the presentation as you can see it's from a score of six this six is actually a
three-part score so we have one two three here so with this one uh for a score of two is your
power and speed your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression of energy is also scored out
of two as well so we'll start off with the power and speed so with this one whether it's your
blocks your kicks your strikes your punches anything you are that you do you need to be
nice and strong and it has to be fast as well so that it's one thing to have a very
strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be both strong and fast to get
high in that in that category the next part is your rhythm so the rhythm uh when you do start
your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern it's not just really fast all the way through
it's not slow all the way through there's a slow fast slow fast kind of aspect to it as well
so you do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also scored out of the two the last
expression of energy so what is expression of energy so that's basically uh how loud you shout
so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well so let's say you're doing your pattern
really well it's really fast and it's strong the rhythm is really great but you're not shouting
very loud or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of tell oh you're not really confident you're
a little bit nervous so that's why we need to kind of improve on on as well so i'm just coming out to
so with this one for color belts and black belts it's actually scored a little bit differently so
if you're a color belt you'll actually uh your average so where where the judges actually mark
you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your average so say you did uh you did all right you
did average compared to everyone else your score for one two and three it'll start from a 1.1 so
if you're less than average you're going to score from a 1.1 so if you're less than average you're
going to score from a 1.1 so if you're less than average you're going to score from a 1.1 so in the
judges eyes you might go down to say for your power and speed you might get a 1 or even a 0.9
if you did really great you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4 so each individual uh category you need
to obviously get as high as you can uh if you're a black belt generally depending on the competition
it will be scored from a 1.3 so 1.3 would be your average uh that you start from so say your parent's
average average you might get scored a one point say let's say 1.4 for now say
your rhythm was only about average it wasn't amazing it might be just a 1.3
but let's say you didn't shout very loud so your expression of energy your
average was 1.3 it might drop to say let's say 1.0 so with this one we'll
come over down to this side so with this one as I was saying it's a total of
10 so let's see and for presentation we had 1.7 1 2 3 so you had a 3.7 let's say
you made 15 mistakes so with this one obviously don't be too discouraged if
you do get pretty high in your mistakes this is with the judges
we have three judges usually at the panel and each judge obviously it's very
subjective so from their point of view you might have made a lot of mistakes or
you may I may have made not a lot of mistakes as well so that's why we have
the three judges and we average in that as well okay so say we did our 15
mistakes very small mistakes so if they're all minus 0.1 you'd be 1.5 so
you go 4.0 minus 1.5 which equals 2.5 so this would be your accuracy score so
with our presentation like before we're saying we've got a 3.7 here so we add
these numbers at the after the judges are finished scoring so you would get for
this pattern a 6.2 which is actually very good so I'll just talk about a
little bit more now about this number here
so if you're a color belt if you're a yellow or above and you do your patterns
it's not uncommon generally for a color belt the average is about a 4 to 5 so if
you get a number between 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern that's actually
generally considered pretty good so anything above that you can consider
yourself pretty good if you're a black belt
the average would say because we're talking here about the higher
presentation as an average anything from 5 to 6 is actually considered pretty
pretty good and anything over a 7 is actually considered almost world-class
so if you get a 7 for any of your patterns you generally need to pat
yourself on the back you did an amazing job so we just went through the
round of poomsae scoring so just remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation
is a 6.0 accuracy is judge during your pattern presentation is after and then we
get two scores that we add up and we get that number so with this one obviously
say I was I was judge number one I would give you a 6.2 there was another
judge on the other side maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did
so maybe this one would be a little bit lower it might be a 5 point something
another judge on the other side they scored a little bit higher so we'd get
the three numbers and then we'd average that as well so I hope this helped you
guys so make sure you enjoy your poomsae competitions and anytime I make sure
obviously you record down your numbers as well so it's very important to keep
track of your numbers and see if you're improving overall as well
okay so this is minor error yeah okay major error real time so we cannot pause
to your video and power and speed right after coordination and tempo and
expression of energy okay
and we can start
oh
okay
so
so so so so so so so so so so so so
so so
so so so
I'm going to start with the bb
so
lol
pull
Thank you.